you had 12 million in the bank yeah and
you're about to screw it up let's just
do this in the next yep 120 seconds
I'm fully levered I'm in just two stocks
I'm literally tonsils deep into these
stocks yeah
the market unwinds I think that we've
had tonsils leave
that's not swear jar material though 13
it's pretty bad so we have to bleep the
market on wines there but within a
couple weeks basically i am i find
myself way underwater just way way
underwater
i owe four million dollars in my own
name I'm not
I have no I'm not behind an LLC on this
it's just in my own name did you puke
and when you have no here's the thing
there becomes there's a level where
amounts are so big they almost feel
fictional Yeah right like totally it
might be easier 204 million dollars than
it is to a $50,000 yeah
and I also I didn't have any kids I
didn't have a house yeah I was sleeping
on my buddy's couch in Park City Utah
ostensibly attending law school but
really co-managing a record store and so
I it just it was so virtual but I that
was more money than I ever thought I
would make in my lifetime yeah and so I
owed that eventually I I had I came out
to the valley I'd been a law student I
did well in law school by never going
into the class and just taking the exams
I came out to the valley
the guys at Fenwick and West were nice
enough to give me a job that's top to
your law firm
yeah they know you were four million and
no no they knew I was a loose cannon but
they didn't know I was four million in
debt but so there I was during the day
working for them at night writing
business plans rebranding what is e
trade or whatever this thing what do
they do they come to you and say you owe
is four million there's a lawsuit start
how does that get resolved yeah it's all
of the above so there's collection
agencies like there's people I'm sure a
lot of your listeners have been hounded
by collection agents not before it's
nasty yeah and so but I worked out
payment plans and started grinding on it
Wow I mean imagine like a mortgage for
the biggest house you can imagine that
you'll never get to own yes twenty
thousand dollars a month to get even and
I didn't
and I didn't want to get I didn't want
to go bankrupt because I really actually
was more than that because interest
rates are a lot higher then ya know what
I mean
percentage yeah so I didn't I didn't
want to declare bankruptcy because I
thought that would get in the way of a
future career so I had to I had to earn
it out Wow crazy oh I did but along the
way I get a job as a lawyer things are
going well
for days before September 11th my law
firm fires me and a bunch of other
people it's just a massive layoff
bloodletting yes the economy is falling
apart for like four days I have job
prospects and then September 11th
happened and it obviously cast my woes
in a much lighter note because everybody
else's yeah so as people are joining me
yeah grinds to a halt and so I have to
go out and hustle and so I started going
to every networking event I could find
in Silicon Valley and I mean not just
the Churchill club I mean you want to
see condition entrepreneurs the Chinese
software professionals Association
you're going to every single special in
the world internet forum all of them and
I can't afford to pay for these things
because I have no money so I'm sneaking
in the kitchen yeah yeah cuz I speak
Spanish your punk rocking it yeah and I
have a business cards just as Chris
Sacca attorney-at-law and business guy
and I'm giving it to people and you know
mentor mindset if somebody makes eye
contact with you going they want to talk
to you I don't know if that's or not but
I went in anyway so all told people
would be like oh you sound like a good
kid things will work out for you and I
Pat me on my back I'm like you don't
understand like I'm living in a hovel in
Foster City and I need to make rent or
I'm moving back to Buffalo New York
right like you have no idea how
desperate I am and it's kind of hard to
make these 4 million dollar payments on
a bartender salary yeah so I am scraping
anything I can and ultimately what I did
was I just rebranded myself I created a
thing called the Salinger group it just
sounded mnemonic and familiar yeah and I
had Johnny Salinger my now wife crystal
who's been in my close friend forever I
had her design a business card for me it
looked awesome how did you wind up with
such a great woman if you were complete
fraud up until this boy we betrayed
wreck some people yes some people are
attracted disaster but like but but so I
she build me this business car and I had
this great site it's not the saundra
group calm isn't up anymore but you can
go to the Internet
archive and you know the wayback machine
it's you'll notice the site says a lot
of nothing it has no address or phone
number but it says a lot of [ __ ]
because I needed to cover any angles
that I was gonna go make money on yeah
yeah and I just went out with this
business card now and I just said we
instead I and people like oh yeah the
saundra group I heard you guys you guys
do good work yeah and so before you know
it she changed Ching I'm getting wrong
up people are hire me as a consultant
they're giving me equity in their
company and like it became a real thing
yeah I started I started actually
building a real business fake it to you
makes up yeah yeah I embodied that
doesn't I'm in fact the saundra grip was
so successful that a bunch of my buddies
had lost their job during that time when
they had gaps in their resume you know
put this under yeah they're like hey
buddy can I can I say I worked as a
sounder group I'm like yeah sure just
tell me what your response yeah I'll
endorse that on rise yeah so and it was
funny everyone kind of fit the sounder
group to just make yeah stay within
their career trajectory well where did
you are you working the Hong Kong office
yeah can I say I did healthcare
consulting yeah sure buddy it's all good
challenge your group so you know you put
on the website the healthcare progress
you go into your um going to your
LinkedIn database now or you're your own
hiring you know whoever's listening
right now in your company and I bet
you've got some saundra group employees
there and you want the Salinger group
people I bet they're hustlers yeah yeah
yeah I mean if you're willing to
fictionalize about it to make itself
bedroom so good